deux ans après sa mort la maison de
réjean ducharme situé sur cette rue de
la petite bourgogne a été vendu mais son
bureau de travail et son atelier seront
déménagées reconstituer tels que
retrouver à son décès on va les remonter
à l'identique avec la même hauteur de
plafond les mieux ça va être notés comme
seul et on ne voit pas d'entreprises à
la fois légende de la littérature
québécoise écrivain fantôme
réjean ducharme a écrit des
chefs-d'oeuvre dont l'avalée des avalés
et l'hiver de force
c'est le musée de la civilisation à
québec qui présentera ses trouvailles
d'ici 2022
le fait de retrouver les oeuvres
complètes de nelligan dans la
bibliothèque de chevet donc dans cet
espace qui était très intime c'est un
moment qui était particulièrement
émouvant la bibliothèque de réjean
ducharme comptait 1400 livres
ce dictionnaire italiens français et est
ouvert tout près de son bureau le jour
de son décès seddik sauna il y en avait
partout
seddik sauna ils sont
ils sont usés ils sont presque revenus à
allaitant végétales ils sont et du gros
tu es pour les tenir en simple lecteur
boulimique réjean ducharme écoutait
aussi beaucoup de musique
l'éventail de disques on peut retrouver
il y avait autant du grunge que des
vinyles des ventures je dois vous avouer
que j'ai trouvé indice dow jones perd
pas dans le bureau de réjean ducharme ça
a été une des surprises qu'on a eu au
moment de faire l'emballage et des
objets
[Musique]
pour les amis de réjean ducharme cette
reconstitution de son bureau est un
cadeau pour les chercheurs c'est
prodigieux parce que c'est une oeuvre en
soi
moi j'ai toujours rêvé évidemment
d'entrer dans la caverne d'ali baba et
de voir de quoi ça al'air son lieu de
travail ce lieu de création là où tout
est né mais parmi tous ces objets
l'écrivain n'a laissé aucun manuscrit
inédit parce que j'étais avec lui quand
même la dernière année et il m'avait dit
il ya rien de caché l'homme
vous ne trouvez rien parce que ça fait
un bout quand même qui l'avait arrêté
d'écrire
l'exposition qui sera présentée d'ici
2022 au musée de la civilisation à
québec sera temporaire la succession au
de réjean ducharme lui trouver un
endroit permanent car les amis de
l'écrivain fantôme veulent préserver sa
mémoire encore longtemps ici louis
philippe ouimet radio canada montréal